(mellow music)
- [Robert] Before we even
started the design process,
I showed Sue some diagrams.
One was built into the hillside,
but it was contrasted
with the second option
which was more of the tree-house version.
Sue knew exactly what she wanted.
- The way I survived the first weeks
after my husband's death was to be
up in the trees of Great Falls.
So when I was ready to
move out of the house
where Mike died, what I
immediately looked for
was a lot that was full of trees.
So I could get that feeling,
that feeling of being in nature,
which was so critical to my
healing in those early days.
(mellow music)
- The first thing we did is
to look carefully at the site,
at the various experiences
that were possible.
And that meant thinking
three-dimensionally,
not just about the ground plane,
not just about where you're
walking on the ground,
but what's up in the air.
- Welcome to my Tree-house.
This place is my haven, my
oasis, and my work of art.
The experience walking into my home starts
whenever you walk across
a floating walkway.
- [Robert] That bridge-like entry is
the first kind of moment
of leaving the land,
and you're also seeing
the nature below that,
almost like you're on a
boardwalk in a nature preserve.
- This is my Great Room.
One of the beauties of
this room is you can see
front-to-back and side-to-side
the trees everywhere,
and also have this beautiful fireplace
and my poet's corner all
combined into this room.
(uplifting music)
What I love about this corner is
that you can take a look
at the entire viewshed.
So that's a term that Robert,
my architect, taught me
where you're taking a look at
the open space ahead of you.
- She was very clear
about what she wanted,
but she never said what style.
And to me, that is actually
the essence of modern.
It's not about style.
It's about addressing the
actual needs that you have.
And that's a form of freedom,
and that's a form of liberation.
- This is my screen porch
and this is a room that
I spend so much time in
all weekend long.
These screens are next level.
They're floor to ceiling,
with only a bifurcation in the
middle for safety purposes,
they let you feel like you're outside.
So this room is a very much of a draw
for when people come over.
They want to spend time
on the screen porch.
- I think on the screen porch
more so than anywhere else in the house,
you feel in the trees, you
don't have that layer of glass.
It is a little bit dangerous,
because you're up so
high, but you're safe.
That's by design (laughs).
- All right, here we are in the kitchen.
So the most beautiful
feature of this kitchen
are these windows.
These are spectacular, the
way that they wrap around,
and you can get a view
of all the different
kinds of trees outside.
And then on a personal note,
one of the parts of the
kitchen that I love the most
is the sink.
So Mike and I, my husband,
at a prior house had
a beautiful sink, this Kallista sink.
And so whenever we were
designing this kitchen,
I wanted to incorporate a
little piece of the past
into the present and the future.
- Because we wanted to take
advantage of that view,
there are no upper
cabinets in this kitchen,
so we had to think about
how to make it functional.
And we solved that by creating
a wall of vertical cabinets
that have the refrigerator
and the pantries,
basically all the storage in one element,
that's very convenient to the island.
- My true favorite room
in my house is my office.
One of the biggest ways that I healed
after the loss of my husband was reading.
Right out of the gate I read the classic,
"A Year of Magical
Thinking" by Joan Didion,
and many others that told
stories about grief and loss.
So sometimes when I'm on a work call,
I'll just climb up on my
couch and pull out a book
that I think is appropriate for the person
I'm talking to on a call.
I'll remember something, an
insight that I gained from one,
and I'll want to pull it out for someone.
Oh my gosh, Dave Grohl the
most hilarious, awesome book
but full of life lessons,
because people think that
nobody talks about loss,
but every single memoir I have here
has an example of how someone
has gotten through loss.
For Dave Grohl, that was
his Nirvana experience.
(mellow guitar music)
Here on the master bedroom
level, you get to see the canopy.
So that's why I refer to
this floor as my bird's nest.
I'm a bird tucked in the
very top of the trees.
Of course, we get to have the feeling
of a floor to ceiling window
consuming the entire room.
But when you look at it in reality,
there is a space on either side.
So that space is designed
to make the windows
more economical,
so that the window company can make them
more in their normal thresholds,
rather than it being completely custom.
- There's a benefit, cost
benefit, that we always look at.
So that extra inch, is it
really worth, you know, $5,000?
Probably not.
- And then also you'll notice
there are no shades on these windows.
I'm so high up, no one's seeing into them.
And in addition, it
just makes me feel like
I'm more in nature.
I'm an early riser, so
I get up with the sun,
sometimes from my bed I watch the sun rise
through the windows,
and watch all the colors of the sky,
and that's the way I like it.
(uplifting music)
When it came to designing this space here
in the master bath,
I had lived 18-years of
marriage with double sinks.
So I kept telling Robert and Ben,
"No, we'll put two sinks in here."
And they kept looking at me
very nicely and very kindly,
and didn't wanna point out
that I was just a single person,
and what would I need a double sink for?
So we had a come-to-Jesus moment
where we were staring at the
plans at their New York office,
and I finally had to
really absorb the fact
that I was a single person and
a single sink would be great.
Is this style of architecture
what Mike Deagle would've wanted?
No, but that's kind of the beauty of it.
I get to express myself in it
while knowing that whatever it would take
for us to heal and move forward,
whatever it would take
to support our lives,
he would support.
One really precious thing
to me is this letter
that my husband wrote me 10-years almost
before he died.
"Sweetheart, I was just thinking about
"how much I missed you.
(melancholy music)
"Sometimes when I fly, I
think about what would happen
"if I passed away and
you, Connor and Kendall
"were without me.
"I wonder, will they be okay?
"Have I done all I can
so that they will be?
"If indeed something should happen,
"know that all I would want for you all
"is to move forward with your lives,
"living them fully and happily.
"Your devoted husband, Michael."
Oh, look!
(mellow music)